hello and welcome to support vector
machines in our my name is Pete Ferrari
and I am with the simply learned team
and today we're going to cover support
vector machines SVM in the our
programming language support vector
machine is a binary classifier a
supervised machine learning algorithm
and in this video we will learn what all
that means so what's in it for you well
we'll discuss what machine learning is
what classification is and what is
support vector machine we'll also cover
understanding support vector machine
understanding an extension of support
vector machine the SVM kernel and we'll
cover a use case classifying horses and
mules so what is machine learning the
ability of a computer to learn from data
without explicit programming the machine
learns from the existing data and
predicts future data so our data set
must contain known outcomes and it must
have sufficient amount of data with
those known outcomes so that the machine
can learn take the data and just it
apply the machine learning algorithm the
algorithm learns creates a model
analyzes the model and then uses that
model to make predictions machine
learning algorithms come in three major
flavors supervised learning algorithms
unsupervised learning algorithms and
reinforcement learning and today we'll
cover classification under supervised
learning supervised meaning the data set
has known outcomes if it were
unsupervised it would not have known
outcomes and we wouldn't have the
categories or classes necessary for the
machine to learn but under supervised
learning we do have the known outcomes
in the data set and under supervised
learning there are two major types of
machine learning algorithms
classification which we'll cover today
support vector machine and regression
classification you predict categories
and in regression you generally predict
values so while we look at supervised
learning keep in mind that
classification can really be considered
multi-dimensional in the sense that
sometimes you only have two classes
yes or no to her faults and sometimes
you have more than two classes sometimes
you have say under risk management or
risk modeling low risk medium risk or
high risk and SVM is a binary classifier
it is a classifier used for those
true/false yes/no types of
classification problems and in
supervised learning features are
important if there are a lot of features
SVM maybe the better classification
algorithm choice as opposed to say
logistic regression
so for supervised learning the computer
is presented with example inputs and
their desired outputs those known
outcomes and the goal is to learn a
general rule that map's inputs to those
outputs for example bug detection or
customer churn or stock price prediction
not the value of the stock price but
whether or not it will rise or fall and
weather prediction sunny not sunny rain
no rain a classification algorithms
generally take passed data data that we
have those known outcomes train the
model take new data once the models
trained ingest it into the model and
create predictions is it a truck or is
it a car and keep in mind that I said
features are important and the number of
features whether or not those features
are applicable to your problem is a
whole different discussion but in some
sense you know probably intuitively that
the color of a car really isn't
indicative of whether or not it's a car
or a truck but the length of the vehicle
or the number of axles or the weight or
the amount of seating may be more
applicable to the algorithm into
training of the model so what is support
vector machine support vector machine or
SVM is a type of classification
algorithm which classifies data based on
its features an SVM will classify any
new element into one of those two
classes so we'll give it some inputs the
algorithm will segregate and classify
the data and then create the outputs and
next one we ingest new data an unknown
fruit variable in this example the
algorithm will
correctly classify the fruit Apple
versus orange so now let's an understand
what an SVM is and if you want to
understand support vector machine you
really need a good example and I know
that cricket is a wonderful game I don't
know a lot about it but I know it's very
popular around the world and we're going
to use cricket as an example of SVM so
will classify cricket players into
batsman or bowler
using the runs to wicket ratio so a
player with more runs would be
considered a batsman and a player with
more wickets would be considered a
bowler and if we could take a data set
say of people cricket players with runs
and wickets in columns next to their
names we could create a plot a
two-dimensional plot in this example
clear separation between cricket players
considered bowlers and those cricket
players considered batsman and you don't
always have a data set this clean where
there is a clear segregation of data
bowlers versus batsmen but for the sake
of understanding SVM this example does
well so before we do any separation
before we apply any high-level
mathematics
let's just take a look at an unknown
value a new data coming into our data
set and that datum we don't know what
class it belongs to that datum is a
bowler or a batsman we know that much
but we don't know should we consider
that cricket player a batsman or a
bowler and so we want to draw a decision
boundary some type of line separating
the two classes so that we can use that
decision boundary to classify the new
data point of course we could draw lines
there's a yellow line a green line a
blue line there's actually not just
three lines but an infinite number of
lines that we could draw between those
two classes so which one do we pick and
this is kind of reminiscent of simple
linear regression where we find the line
of best fit we want the line of best
separation we want a line that clearly
separates those two groups as much as
possible once we have the correct line
we would be able to classify
the new data point but in this example
you can see if we pick yellow the new
data point would be a bowler but if we
picked green or blue the new data point
would be a batsman so we need the one
that best separates the data what line
best separates the data will find the
best line by computing the maximum
margin from equidistant support vectors
now support vectors in this context
simply means the two points one from
each class that are closest together but
that maximize the distance between them
or the margin so the word vector here
you may think well he really means
points data points well in
two-dimensional space yes and maybe even
in three-dimensional space well once you
get into higher dimensional spaces when
you get more and more features in your
data set you have to consider these as
vectors you can no longer really
describe them as points so we call them
vectors and the reason their support
vectors is because the two vectors that
are closest together that maximize the
distance between the two groups support
the algorithm so that's why we call them
support vectors so if you look at our
example there are a couple of points at
the top that are pretty close to one
another and a couple of points at the
bottom of that graph that are pretty
close to each other and I'm not really
sure looking at the graph which two are
closest
but clearly those points are the ones we
need to consider the rest of the other
points are too far away from the rest of
the other points in other words the
bowler points are far to the right and
the batsman data points are far to the
left so we'll look at these four points
to begin with mathematically we would
calculate the distance among all of
these points and we would minimize that
distance once we pick the support
vectors we'll draw a dividing line and
then measure the distance from each
support vector to the line the best line
will always have the greatest margin or
distance between the support vectors if
we consider the yellow line as a
decision boundary the player with the
new data point would
be considered a bowler the margins don't
appear to be maximum though so maybe we
can come up with a better line so let's
take other support vectors and we'll
draw the decision boundary between those
and then we will calculate the margin
and notice now that the unknown data
point the new value would be considered
a batsman we would continue doing this
and obviously a computer doesn't much
quicker than a human being over and over
and over again until we found the
correct decision boundary with a
greatest margin and in this case if you
look at the green decision boundary the
green line appears to have the maximum
margin compared to the other two and so
let's consider this the boundary of
greatest margin and now classify our
unknown data value and now clearly it
belongs in the batsman's class the green
line divides the data perfectly because
it has the greatest margin or the
maximum margin between the support
vectors and now we can have confidence
in our classification that the new data
point is indeed a batsman technically
this dividing line is called a
hyperplane and the reason it's called a
hyperplane will become a little bit more
evident in a few minutes
generally in two-dimensional space we
consider those lines but in
three-dimensional space and higher
dimensional spaces they're considered
planes or hyper planes so we always tend
to refer to them as hyper planes and the
hyper plane that has the maximum
distance from the support vectors is the
one we want
so sometimes called the positive
hyperplane D+ is the shortest distance
to the closest positive point and d-
sometimes called the negative hyperplane
as the closest shortest distance to the
closest negative point and the sum of D
positive indeed negative is called the
distance margin so if you calculate
those two distances and add them up
that's the distance margin and we always
want to maximize that if we don't
maximize it we can have a miss
classification and you can see the
yellow margin is much smaller than the
green margin so this problems that is
2-dimensional because the classification
is only between two classes and so we
would call this a linear SVM now we're
going to take a look at
svm and if you notice in this picture
and this is a great depiction of a plane
not a line this is three dimensional
space so that's the plane that separates
those two classes so what if our
two-dimensional data looks like this
what if there's no clear linear
separation between the two classes and
machine learning parlance we would say
that these are not linearly separable
how could we get support vector machine
to work on data that looks like this
since we can't separate it into two
classes using a line what we're going to
do and clearly there's no line I mean
convince yourself there's no line that
goes and separates those two classes so
what we would do is we would apply some
type of transformation to a higher
dimension we would apply a function
called a kernel function to the data set
such that the data set would be
transformed into a higher dimension a
dimension high enough where we could
clearly separate the two groups the two
classes in this case with a plane much
the same way you saw the picture a few
slides ago where the plane was
separating the two classes here we
clearly could draw some planes between
the green dots and the red dots and of
course we could draw an infinite number
of planes separating those two classes
but we would draw the one that would
maximize the margin so if we let R be
the number of dimensions then the kernel
function would convert a given
two-dimensional space to a three
dimensional space and as I said once the
data is separated in three dimensions we
can apply SVM and separate the two
groups using a two dimensional plane and
this is analogous and the higher
dimensions and that last picture on the
right-hand side would be some type of
depiction of a higher dimension
hyperplane and there are more than one
type of kernel function there's Gaussian
RBF kernel sigmoid kernel polynomial
kernel depending on the dimension and
how you want to transform the data there
are more than one choice for kernel
functions so now let's go through a use
case let's take a look at horses and
mules
see if we can use SVM to classify some
new data so the problem statement is
classifying horses and mules and we're
going to use height and weight as the
two features and obviously horses and
mules typically in general tend to weigh
differently and tend to stand taller so
we'll take a data set will import the
data set we'll make sure we have our
libraries the e10 7-1 library has
support vector machine algorithms
built-in we'll compute the support
vectors using the library once the data
is used to train the algorithm we'll
plot the hyperplane get a visual sense
of how the data is separated and if it's
two-dimensional or three-dimensional
that's great
remember if it's higher dimensional it's
tough to plot those and then we'll use
the new model the trained model to
classify new values in general we would
have a training set a test set and then
ingest the new data but for our example
we're just going to use the whole data
set to train the algorithm and then see
how it performs and once we see how it
performs we'll see did we get a horse
did we predict a horse when we had a
horse did we predict a mule when we had
a mule so here's the our code of course
if you want to run this our code you'll
have to install R and then our studio
then you'll have to ingest the data and
then you'll have to create an indicator
variable to help us with our plots we'll
install our libraries install a package
if you don't already have it installed I
do and then call the library up into the
our session that you're working we'll
create the data frame from the data that
was ingested we will then view the data
frame and of course we have to explore
the data frame hoping that we don't have
missing values or we don't have outliers
if we do have missing values or outliers
we'll have to either impute those values
or delete those values but in this case
let's hope we don't have any and now for
a quick demo on support vector machines
so we have a working directory where my
data is stored and I'm going to set the
working directory to that data source
and read the data file into our I now
I'm going to create a vector that really
is just an indicator variable it's the
negative ones
the ones that indicate whether it's a
mule or a horse negative one for a mule
positive one for a horse so I'll create
that vector and svm there's a great
package e10 seven one great library that
has the support vector machine functions
that we're going to use and now I'm
going to create the data frame I'm going
to take my data and I'm going to add to
it the is horse vector
and now let's just take a peek and as
you can see there's the height weight
and whether or not the animal was a mule
or a horse
so remember machine learning we take a
data source with known outcomes and we
apply our algorithm to that data source
in this case a data frame of heights
weights and the indicator variable and
then we use the machine learning
algorithm to learn from that data with
those known results so now let's plot
the data the height versus weight and as
you can see the horses tend to be a lot
taller and weigh a lot more than the
mules so now let's run our algorithm our
SVM model against the data and the key
here is that it's a linear model and
we've run it and great now we have a
model let's look at the summary of the
model and as you can see there's the
formula that it ran and some of the
information about the vectors and the
classes and there are two support
vectors so now let's find those two
support vectors on our graph and this
might be a little hard to see the orange
outline around this point and this point
indicate that those are the two vectors
that will support this model and thus we
call them the support vectors now let's
get the parameters of the hyperplane
from the model and let's plot a line
that will be our hyperplane there's our
hyperplane line and therefore to the
left and below our mules and to the
right and above our horses above that
line let's take a few new observations
and I've encoded these so that it would
be illustrative well take these new
observations and we'll plot them and I'm
going to generate a new plot red being
the horses black dots being the mules
I'll create an X and y-axis I'm gonna
plot three dots and you can see one of
them the green dot the first one canna
falls near the mules the blue one kind
of falls near the horses and visually we
might conclude hate one's a mule one's a
horse but what about the orange dot well
for the orange dot we really need our
hyperplane we really need something to
clearly indicate which side it's on and
of course by looking
at this data visualization you can tell
that the orange is probably a mule and
let's verify those results by sticking
those observations into our model and
predict some outcomes and down below you
can see that for the three data points
one two and three the first one the
green one was negative 1 that's a mule
the second one was a positive one that's
blue it's the Blue Point which was a
horse and the third one which we weren't
sure about but clearly the SVM model
correctly predicted that that Third
Point would be a negative 1 would be a
mule and we can visually see that by the
hyperplane on the graph so that's a
quick example of SVM in general support
vector machines are binary classifiers
we don't use them for higher level
classification if you had three or more
classes you might want to use something
like random forests what applications
you can use it for face detection text
categorization image classification and
bioinformatics really anywhere that you
have the need to classify things into
two groups
so the key takeaways in this video we
learned about what machine learning is
and some of the different types of
machine learning algorithms supervised
and unsupervised and reinforcement
learning and we focused primarily on
supervised learning and support vector
machines understanding support vector
machines as a binary classifier and the
intuition between the problem and the
solution take the two closest points in
the two classes that maximize the margin
or the distance between them we looked
at what happens if your two classes are
not linearly separable an understanding
SVM kernel and how you could map a
non-linear separable problem to a higher
dimension and thereby creating a clear
separation and then we looked at the use
case of horses and mules it's a small
data set but very indicative of how SVM
works and then the applications of
support vector machine and although we
only covered for face detection text
categorization image classification and
bioinformatics there are literally
thousands and thousands of applications
of SVM
and that's it if you'd like the code
that we use in this example or you have
any questions or concerns please post
them in the comments we have a great
library of these videos up on our
YouTube site and we hope you subscribe
to it and watch them all they're very
helpful especially to beginner data
scientists thanks again this is Pete
Ferrari and happy data sciencing hi
there if you like this video subscribe
to the simple learn YouTube channel and
click here to watch similar videos de
nerd up and get certified click here